This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern. and worry. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
On the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed I will be his last target.
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. And formally, welcome back to this little mini-series I'm doing this week,
focusing on how we can create our dream life in our 20s, where I'm going to be kind of combining all the best advice, the psychology, the evidence, personal philosophy and more from across all these different dimensions in our 20s that I think cause us a lot of strife. So things like our careers, our finances, love, friendships, the future, and of course our personal growth. So this is part two of this week's series where we're going to be talking about love, dating, friendship and also focusing on some of that deeper emotional and psychological work that I think we need to undertake in this decade. If you haven't listened to part one, please go and listen to that episode where we kind of cover more tips around managing career anxiety, feeling stuck, taking risks, and we talk about money
as well, but also you can listen to this episode completely on its own if the questions you're facing, your dilemmas, are more to do with kind of your interpersonal relationships and some of that deeper emotional content of our 20s that this decade really brings to the surface. I think the concerns we have around our future and even our present as well do fall into these different categories. We worry about being happy in our jobs, not tying ourselves down to some stagnant 9 to 5, getting the most out of these formative years. But then on a deeper level, we have a lot of questions around building meaningful relationships. You know, how many friends do we actually need? Are we settling down too quickly? Should we be dating more, dating less? What is the right
way to do this time? What is the right way to make the most out of this decade? I think the reason we worry so much about love and relationships in particular, just on like a universal human level, is, well, A, they are incredibly significant and impactful. And I think B, we don't want to live with regret that maybe we fell in love too soon or too late or with the wrong person as humans regret is a really powerful motivator because it is one of the only emotional experiences that we can't fix. What's in the past is in the past and our recognition, I think, of that permanency of all of those decisions really bleeds into the present and it causes us to be very overwhelmed by the many avenues and choices that are presented to us because we don't want to choose wrong and then potentially
close an important door, especially during this period where we feel like endless doors are open to us that we're still in this kind of free flowing state of being able to make choices and mistakes. So we're going to talk about that a little bit more. But I think additionally, one of the other reasons a lot of us are looking for answers or an answer to some of these questions. is because we have been sold a very glamorous idea that there is a correct way to live your 20s and also an incorrect way, you know, shows like sex in the city and friends. Honestly, any movie or TV show focused on people in their 20s living in New York is such a major culprit. The media really delivers very targeted and effective cues that sell a fantasy of what this decade should
look like, one of young love and chaos and partying, millions of friends, high-paying jobs when no one really ever actually works. And I think, firstly, that's not everyone's idea of happiness. Like we discussed in part one, everyone is going to have a different conception of what is going to bring them fulfillment in this decade. But secondly, this glamorous depiction of what we should be doing is not really, it's not reality. And, Yet that is really our only reference point for a lot of us. And you can feel like if you're not meeting this image, that your life is off track or that you're missing out or that somehow you're going about this wrong and you're going to really
be haunted later in life that you didn't take more risks or you didn't live this romantic, glamorous 20-something fantasy. So I think we really need to let go of these narrow ideas of what we thought our life was going to look like based on fiction or based on expectations. And when we give ourselves that freedom, I think our lives really turn out better than what we had in mind, not because it's any easier, but because it's your experience. Those experiences and memories that you're choosing to make, even if they're different from what everyone is telling you to do, they get to be yours and you get to make them special and
romanticize the things that maybe the media and those around you don't. You know, our 20s are a lot more messy than we've been told. Our problems are not neatly wrapped up in some plot twist by the end of the episode. We feel our emotions so intensely. So I want to do this episode as a bit of a reality check for those of us who are maybe worried that we're falling behind or we're missing out because I promise it's not just you feeling that way. Every single one of us is feeling a little bit stuck in some aspect of our lives. And anyone who is pretending that they haven't all sorted out is either faking it, do they make it, which I appreciate, or it's in for a very rude awakening,
because every single one of us is doing this for the first time. We are all new to life. And with that, every new year, every new situation we encounter, and the stories we're going to create, they're going to be different. There is no right way to live our lives during this period. And you don't need to be living someone else's storyline to be happy. On the other hand, though, I do think that this decade promises a lot in terms of freedom, in terms of opportunity and chaos and fun, and that emotional richness that we really need
to reach out and grab. We really have a duty to give. of our future selves some good stories, but also some important connections and some meaningful lessons as well. So a big focus of our last episode was on regret. And I think when we talk about love and relationships and friendships, there's a lot of possibility for that. But we know that we are more likely to regret the decisions that we didn't make than the ones that we do. And that's really the theme that is going to flow through all of these tips. If in doubt, do it. especially in your 20s. Always fall in love as much as you can say yes to everything,
but also don't be afraid to say goodbye. You know, this is your time to set yourself up for future success whilst also not putting too much pressure on yourself. And I think when we break that down and really focus on some of those core properties that is going to allow us to really create our dream life, it becomes a lot easier to feel like we're allowed to have our own story. and feel like our mistakes are not going to be life-ending or cause us to live with regret. So let's talk about all of this, what we need to prioritize to, quote unquote, make the most out of this decade. But also I would say some of the things that we need to de-center that can be a later issue, an issue for our 30s or our 40s.
We're going to talk love, friendships, and of course personal growth, bringing as much of the psychological. and the evidence to the table and some of the studies as well because they are so fascinating and boundless and just really, really applicable. So if you're facing some of those existential questions, if you're worried that your formative years might be slipping by, I promise we are all in it together. I'm here with you. And hopefully I can give you some of my hard earned advice to pull yourself out of that rabbit hole and create your dream situation, create your dream.
life in your 20s. So without further ado, let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific. con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode,
we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. The reason I think a lot of us face this insecurity that we're doing,
doing our 20s wrong is because we are sold something. We are given this example of what this decade should look like that is full of contradictions. You know, you need to have a million friends, but also quality over quantity and, you know, young love and childhood sweethearts, but also you need to get out there. You need to have an abundant dating experience. Don't sleep with too many people, but you also need to have all those wild sexual stories. You need to party hard and do stupid things, but also make sure you're prioritizing self-care and taking care of your body. And so we're stuck in this like dilemma where we're like, oh my goodness, there are so many different options here. How do I know that by choosing one, I'm not going to look back later and
wish that I'd done more of that other thing? Here's the secret that I've learned. You can do all of that, but you can't do it all at once. This decade is full of seasons and though your age might be linear, your experiences don't need to be because like we said in episode one, you are not a passive agent in your life. If you are unhappy with something at any stage, you can change that. You get to make decisions for yourself at any point. I'm going to start off by talking about friendships because I think that our friendships are incredibly, incredibly defining. You know, there's this very famous theory that you are an amalgamation. mirror of the five people closest to you, you reflect back their qualities and their values and
their personalities. And I have a really deep belief that it is the people of your 20s that make your 20s. Our community and our friends. They are the first priority, I think, and really the one that can make or break the so-called dream life in this decade. So let's start off by talking about these unique relationships. Firstly, I'm not going to pretend that it's easy to make friends in your adulthood. We all know it's super tough. I'm sure a lot of us have found that people really stick to their groups and what they know sometimes at the detriment of more fulfilling connection. I think every single one of us sometimes struggles with this feeling that we don't have enough friends, that we could have more friends. I call it this thing, the roller coaster of loneliness.
and I was talking to a friend about it the other day, every six months or three months, I'll get this deep, despairing feeling that I am incredibly lonely and I have no one in my life. And I know that's not true. It always lasts for about a week and then I come out of it the other side. And as I've spoken more to my friends, I've realized that this is really common. We go through these lulls and these dips and these plateaus in which we feel like we don't have enough people around us to bring us joy. So I'm not going to sell you some secret formula because I know that it's very hard. Even when we have an abundance of friends, it's hard to appreciate them. But something I've found
that has helped me truly cultivate the best friendship group and friends I have ever had, the people who genuinely elevate my life to the next level was to firstly treat everyone I met for the first time like they were already my best friend, that I'd known them my whole life. And secondly, to just say yes to everything. You know, don't allow yourself to shut off certain people just because you think you won't be aligned or because you've become too comfortable. You know, you have to socialize and live with an abundance mentality, especially during this time when we have so much freedom.
We have so many years to develop these connections. And you don't know how these relationships are going to turn out. So I think you have to go to those parties where you don't know. anyone and really put yourself into new situations. If someone asks if you want to grab a drink, yeah, you do. Of course you do. If someone wants you to help them move, yeah, sure. You just got to talk to new people and who cares if they don't like you? Who cares if it doesn't work out? I think it's a worse outcome to walk past a missed connection to maybe miss out on meeting someone wonderful and life changing out of a fear of judgment. Then, you know, potentially face the reality.
that you just weren't connected. I think it takes a while to find good friends. That's something that I've learned. They are rare. It's not going to be an instantaneous connection with everyone. So don't be afraid to go through some trial and error, to put yourself out there, to take a risk and be bold because people, I think, really respond to that. People respond to others who appear confident, who appear assertive, who express interest in them. It's this founding. idea in our psychology of reciprocity. What you give others, they feel compelled to give you back. And I really think that is the secret formula to discovering new relationships and new connections during this decade. Treat everyone like they are already your best friend and this foundational
that you just weren't connected. I think it takes a while to find good friends. That's something that I's learned. They are rare. It's not going to be an instantaneous connection with everyone. So don't be afraid to go through some trial and error, to put yourself out there, to take a risk and be bold because people, I think, really respond to that. People respond to others who appear confident, who appear assertive, who express interest in them. It's this founding. idea in our psychology of reciprocity. What you give others, they feel compelled to give you back. And I really think that is the secret formula to discovering new relationships and new connections during this decade. Treat everyone like they are already your best friend and this foundational
idea of reciprocity. Give them what you want them to give you back. Something else I think is important to learn during our 20s is that sometimes we come across people who just don't like us. And the thing is that someone else's opinion of you is not your problem. It is really none of your business. It's bothering them more than it should ever bother you. Unless they've really proven that they deserve to be in your life, unless they've proven that they are a good friend, their opinion is really none of your business. It's not something that should be causing you any stress.
it's just someone's thoughts and you have your own thoughts and your own beliefs around your goodness and your value in someone's life. I also think that something that I have personally realized is that you can never have too many friends, especially during this decade. So interestingly, there was a recent study published in the journal Psychology and Ageing, and what it showed was that when it comes to friendships, it's actually quantity over quality that matters in your 20s and vice versa in your 30s. So that pattern, people who had more friends in their 20s but better friends in their 30s, that was a massive predictor of later psychological well-being. And they actually tracked participants for over 30 years. And what they found was that people in their 20s who had more than 10 good friends
we're more likely to have better friends in their 30s and be happier with how they had spent that decade of their lives. So I don't want to say this in terms of almost fearmongering and being like, well, if you don't have that, you know, you're destined to be really lonely and sad. I do not think that is the case. Of course, this is an observational study. There's always nuance. And I think it's equally important to make sure that we are also nurturing those really quality relationships and those longer term friendships as well. So that's tip number two. Make time for old friends. We all know what it's like to outgrow certain people from your past. That's natural. It's normal. It's something you should be embracing to make room for other people. But we really cannot overstate the value of a friend
who has known you for as long as you've kind of known yourself, known your adult self. You know, these are the people who have been beside you for multiple chapters. They probably know you better than you know yourself at some point. And they know those really intimate things that have happened in your past. They've probably carried you through them. And I think the reason these relationships are so important is because those shared memories create very deep emotional bonds. but they're also a really key ingredient to a long-term sense of stability and emotional consistency.
Finding that balance between creating new friendships and trusting and relying on the people that got you there is one that we really need to strike during this decade. And sometimes that can be difficult. I know a lot of us live in new cities or new places. We move for college. We move for jobs. We move for partners. I look at my friendship group now and the people that have known me longest are like scattered across the world.
And it can be very easy to not maintain those relationships and to let them fizzle. I'm telling you now, you will regret that. That is the easy thing to do. But in the long run, I think it's the wrong thing to do because these people are the ones who have already been by your side for so long. So sending them the occasional text, organizing a little FaceTime call. That's like an hour out of your week, an hour out of your month. But when you're older, when maybe you're a little bit wiser, you're going to be really grateful that you put in that time and that effort when you could.
And I also think you get that beautiful opportunity to introduce your old friends and your new friends and to see how you've changed and to kind of build that circle of community around yourself. A lot of what creating our dream life in our 20s is about is making decisions now that might feel like a little bit of extra effort, but in the long run, are an investment in a really beautiful future. And tip number three, if you're looking for ways to have that dream social circle, I know that that's a massive theme that people or a massive kind of goal that a lot of people have during this decade, that dream group, that big posse of friends. Tip number three is to do it yourself.
Be the instigator. Stop waiting for other people to kind of come to you. Remember, it's about agency. So you should be creating those memories that you want to make and invite people into them. You feel like, you know, your friends maybe don't do enough wholesome activities. Well, you should plan them or you want to do more traveling. invite people to come with you. You want to see your friends more often. Reach out. I think the most kind of the most beautiful kinds of people are the ones who create community for those around them. And it's a really beautiful opportunity to be that person. Things like doing dinner nights once a week and inviting, you know, whoever wants to come. I sometimes do that on Sundays. I've been a bit busy recently. But earlier this year and at the end of last year, I got into this habit of
every Sunday I would make like a massive Italian feed and I just kind of float the invite out there. I would invite someone new every time and be like, do you guys want to come over and have dinner and we can play cards? And the amount of people that were like, yeah, I want to do that because there's someone that instigating that sense of community and that sense of connection for them. Things like painting nights, themed parties, asking if people want to go and do a boxing class with you, going for a hike. If you want to have that friendship circle, if you want to have those memories, I think it's a really important thing to realize that someone else isn't going to do that for you. And you really have to be the captain of your own journey and, you know, the captain of
every Sunday I would make like a massive Italian feed and I just kind of float the invite out there. I would invite someone new every time and be like, do you guys want to come over and have dinner and we can play cards? And the amount of people that were like, yeah, I want to do that because there's someone that instigating that sense of community and that sense of connection for them. Things like painting nights, themed parties, asking if people want to go and do a boxing class with you, going for a hike. If you want to have that friendship circle, if you want to have those memories, I think it's a really important thing to realize that someone else isn't going to do that for you. And you really have to be the captain of your own journey and, you1|||know, the captain of your own ship, as corny as that sounds, and be the instigator. I get that a lot of these tips have been about building community and acquiring new friendships and developing old ones and really adding people to that social circle. I think that is a key ingredient. But also, I want to know, and for tip four, I think that we should not be afraid to let go of people just out of nostalgia or loneliness because we feel a sense of obligation or we're, you know, we're scared of being alone. Friendships in our 20s aren't all about new beginnings. They're about endings as well. And I think one of the universal experiences we're going to go through is that friendship breakup, that unique kind of sting of losing someone you never thought that would leave your life. You know, not like an ex-partner or even a parent.
your own ship, as corny as that sounds, and be the instigator. I get that a lot of these tips have been about building community and acquiring new friendships and developing old ones and really adding people to that social circle. I think that is a key ingredient. But also, I want to know, and for tip four, I think that we should not be afraid to let go of people just out of nostalgia or loneliness because we feel a sense of obligation or we're, you know, we're scared of being alone. Friendships in our 20s aren't all about new beginnings. They're about endings as well. And I think one of the universal experiences we're going to go through is that friendship breakup, that unique kind of sting of losing someone you never thought that would leave your life. You know, not like an ex-partner or even a parent.
掌握自己的命运，虽然听起来有点老套，去当那个发起人。我知道很多这些建议都是关于建立社区、结交新朋友、维系老朋友，以及真正把人吸纳到你的社交圈里。我认为这是关键要素。但同时，我也想了解，对于第四个建议，我认为我们不应该害怕仅仅出于怀旧、孤独、感到有义务，或者你知道的，因为害怕孤独而放不下某些人。我们二十多岁的友情并不完全关乎新的开始。它们也关乎结束。而且我认为我们将经历的普遍经历之一，就是那种友谊的破裂，那种失去一个你从未想过会离开你生活的人所带来的独特刺痛。你知道，这不像前任，甚至不像父母。
We think of our friendships as a chosen family or a forever family. But I have a mantra that I repeat to myself all the time, which is that friends are a season, a reason, or a lifetime. sometimes they're there just to guide you through a new period in your life sometimes they're there to teach you a lesson or to teach you something about yourself and then sometimes we get lucky and they're there for the rest of our lives but i think that when we hold on to people out of fear that maybe we won't find someone better and i know that that's not the healthiest mentality to be like oh is there someone better out there for me but what i'm talking about is holding on to those stale that really don't bring you joy anymore.
I want us to think about this hypothetical that I think about a lot when I feel guilt for doing that. Imagine still being friends with every single person that you've known since you were like four years old. Making time for them every week, having a meaningful relationship. It would overwhelm us and we would eventually become a pretty terrible friend. So naturally, I think we are going to be forced to let some of those people go. In the 1990s, actually, this really well-known psychologist called Robin Dunbar, he came to this conclusion that realistically, we can only cognitively and emotionally handle a maximum of 150 social relationships over the course of our lives. And that includes with
friends, with family, with colleagues, with acquaintances, and really the golden number there is no more than 10 really close friends. I think often our 20s are a time in which we are forced to shed some of those relationships that might not be serving us during that moment for people who might better suit our lives and our personalities and our priorities, especially friends who you've not just grown apart from, but who might actually be not contributing to your life in a positive way. people who bring you down, people who aren't adopting the kind of lifestyle that you might want to live, you know, you aren't who you were at 18 or even 21 or later, and really understanding that compatibility
is a hallmark of a good friendship and that compatibility is going to change and wane. That is really important so that we don't feel like we need to almost be greedy with the people in our lives and hold on to every single connection because we're nostalgic or we're afraid of being alone in the future. All right, we're going to take a short break before we come back and tackle love and relationships. So stay tuned. We will be back shortly right after this short break. 2%.
That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier,
这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，如何培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立适应力。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开交流，抛开主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, Never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。名字是 T-W-O-O-Percent，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，千万不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。法则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女友们》的这个新季中，“天哪，这是同一个人。”一群女性发现她们竟然都和同一个惯犯约会过。
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我感觉就像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定自己动手。我说：“哦，去你的吧。”我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。请收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击莉尔·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在播客《Look Back at It》中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们会带你回顾过去，剖析事情的经过，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那一切的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以谈论可卡因，只是想让你们都知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for Blackburn. people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get
我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们第二期讨论可卡因了，所以我开始看出这其中有一条主线了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病，所以。然后你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取
your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good
播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某样东西时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世时做一个好人很重要，还是说你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。没错。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我。加入基尔·盖恩斯，我们在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me. Join meet Keir Gaines is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. Being in our 20s and dating feels like being in the trenches. You know, one part of us wants to like find someone really lovely and settle down, but then we're worried that, you know, if we do it too soon, if we're too young, we're missing out and all these dating experiences and all these fun stories that people seem to have. So there really isn't like a right
二十几岁时的恋爱感觉就像身处战壕。你知道，我们一方面想找一个真正可爱的人安定下来，但另一方面又担心，如果太早这么做，如果年纪太轻，我们会错过所有的恋爱经历，错过其他人似乎都有过的那些有趣故事。所以真的没有所谓的正确
option. And sometimes we can feel like the decisions we're making, the choices we're making. Yeah, they feel great right now. But what if we come to have a little bit of remorse around our decisions or regret that maybe we should have done it differently? Maybe we should have been more open or more closed off to some of those experiences. I think the reason we worry about love and we stress about whether we're doing it the quote unquote right way is because it is a big aspect of our development during this period. It's a really emotionally profound experience. It's what we call in psychology, especially some of our first relationships, our first experience with love. We call it an emotional milestone. So that is a psychologically significant experience
选择。有时候我们会觉得我们正在做出的决定、做出的选择。是的，它们现在感觉很棒。但如果我们后来对自己的决定产生了一点内疚，或者后悔或许当时应该用不同的方式呢？或许我们应该对其中一些经历更加开放或更加抗拒呢？我想我们之所以担忧爱情，纠结于我们是否在以所谓的正确方式去爱，是因为它是我们在这一时期发展的一个重要方面。这是一段情感上极其深刻的体验。这就是我们在心理学中所说的，尤其是我们的第一段恋爱，我们对爱的初体验。我们称之为情感里程碑。所以那是一段具有重大心理意义的体验，
that unlocks new skills, new core memories, new behaviors, and in some ways, new facets of our personality. And I think young love is, I wouldn't say it's overhyped, but it is really romanticized and glamorized because those relationships play a huge role in who we turn out to be in our 20s. And there is no one way to do it correctly. But I think what we want to avoid is three groups of people, the time wasters, the energy stiflers, and the shallow loves. There is no point being in a relationship just for the same. sake of it with any of these types of people during this decade, not for the experience, not to feel like you're ticking off some box, these people will just detract from your life.
它能解锁新的技能、新的核心记忆、新的行为，并在某种程度上解锁我们人格的新层面。我认为年轻时的爱，我不会说它被过度炒作，但它确实被严重浪漫化和美化了，因为这些恋爱关系对我们二十几岁时成为什么样的人起到了巨大的作用。而且没有哪一种方法是绝对正确的。但我认为我们要避开三类人：浪费时间的人、扼杀精力的人和浅薄的爱。在这十年里，跟任何这类人在一起，哪怕仅仅是为了恋爱而恋爱，都是毫无意义的，不是为了经历，也不是为了感觉像是在打卡完成某项任务，这些人只会消磨你的人生。
You know, you don't get that time back, that time you spend investing in people. And I think that they do bring important lessons, but we could have learned those lessons better by perhaps choosing more wisely or choosing to be alone for longer. And I think doing that and claiming that time back for yourself starts by really focusing inward and learning that our own company is better than the company of someone who doesn't give us the love and the attention we deserve. So my first tip for creating your dream life in your 20s centered around love is to learn to enjoy doing things alone. Learn and appreciate the value of solitude and independence. this is perhaps one of the only times when you might have the chance to be completely alone, to have the opportunity to solo travel, to move to a new city without knowing anyone,
你知道，你无法挽回那些时间，那些你用来投资在人身上的时间。而且我认为他们确实带来了重要的教训，但如果我们当初选择得更明智一些，或者选择独处更长时间，我们本可以更好地吸取这些教训。我认为这样做并把时间索回给自己的过程，始于真正将注意力转向内，并认识到我们自己的陪伴，要好于那些不能给予我们应得的爱与关怀的人的陪伴。因此，我关于在二十几岁时围绕爱情创造梦想生活的第一条建议，就是学会享受独自做事情。学会并欣赏独处和独立的价值。这或许是唯一可能让你有机会完全独处的时期之一，有机会独自旅行，搬到一个谁也不认识的新城市，
to not have the obligations of maybe a partner or kids or aging family members, and to just be a little bit selfish with your time and to really enjoy and appreciate that solitude and those periods of maybe even loneliness. Solitude is such an incredibly psychologically profound and sacred experience, but it's also something that we have to choose to prioritize. It's very easy to surround ourselves with people, especially in our 20s, when all of our friends are incredibly accessible and we also have this fear of being alone because we have long-stigmatized solitude.
没有伴侣、孩子或年迈家人的义务，能够对自己的时间稍微自私一点，真正享受并欣赏那种独处以及可能甚至感到孤独的时期。独处是一种极其深奥的心理体验和神圣的体验，但这也是我们必须选择优先考虑的事情。要让自己周围环绕着人非常容易，尤其是在二十几岁的时候，那时我们所有的朋友都极其随叫随到，而且由于我们长期以来对独处带有污名化，我们也对孤独有着这种恐惧。
It's been widely considered as an inconvenience, as something to avoid, a punishment. but when we choose to prioritize being in our own company, learning who we are when we're not surrounded by other people, it's incredibly empowering. So in this study called Narratives of Solitude, amazing research title, these researchers found that when our loneliness, I guess, or when time spent alone is self-imposed,
它被广泛认为是一种不便，是需要避免的事情，是一种惩罚。但当我们选择优先享受独处，去了解当我们不被其他人包围时的自己时，那种感觉会赋予我们无比强大的力量。因此，在这项名为《独处叙事》的研究中——这是一个绝佳的研究标题——这些研究人员发现，当我们的孤独感，或者说独处的时间是自主选择时，
it actually improves things like introspection, and improves self-awareness, and also the quality of the relationships that we do have. So how do we integrate that? I think you need to spend at least one day a month in your own company, doing something without speaking to someone else, without needing someone else to validate your existence or your experiences. And I think that really helps us learn that our existence is not dependent on someone else's acknowledgement of it. Our experiences are significant without someone else's input. I also think learning to be alone during our 20s is a really valuable.
它实际上能改善诸如内省之类的事情，提高自我意识，并改善我们所拥有的关系的质量。那么我们如何将其融入生活呢？我认为你需要每个月至少有一天独处，做一些不用跟别人说话的事情，不需要别人来证实你的存在或你的经历。我认为这确实能帮我们认识到，我们的存在并不取决于别人的承认。我们的经历无需别人的输入也同样意义重大。我也认为学会二十几岁时独处是一项非常宝贵的
skill that will serve you later in life. When perhaps your solitude is not self-imposed, you will know that you have these skills, the ability to enjoy your own company, to actually really, what's the word, like just almost savor it, to really savor the fact that you get time to just know yourself, to be yourself without the opinions, the judgment, the validation of others. Also, I think not being afraid to be alone also allows us to walk away from things that don't serve us, not just in our 20s, but in later life as well. And here I'm talking specifically about relationships. So this leads me to tip number two.
技能，它会在你日后的生活中为你服务。当你的独处可能不是自主选择时，你就会知道你拥有这些技能，有能力享受自己的陪伴，去真正地——怎么说呢——去几乎细细品味它，去真正品味这样一件事：你有时间去了解自己，去成为自己，而无需别人的意见、评判和认可。此外，我认为不怕孤独也能让我们远离那些对我们无益的事物，不仅是在二十几岁时，在后来的生活中也是如此。这里我特指人际关系。这就引出了我的第二条建议。
If you've been in a relationship with someone for less than two years and it feels stressful or toxic or it takes too much time or energy from you, you need to leave. That relationship is not going to get any better. And this decade is not the time to be making deeply emotional mental sacrifices for someone else. That time will come. That time will come later when you're married to someone when it's been 20 or 30 years. And maybe that goes for every decade as well to not be with someone who is requiring you to sacrifice your own identity and your own, I think, time and energy that you would like to devote to yourself. Love should only seek to enhance your life. And if you are fighting for this relationship to live on, especially during these younger years, all of that effort is being taken away from your own development and your own time to put into
如果你和某人交往不到两年，却觉得压力重重、充满毒性，或者它占用了你太多的时间和精力，你需要离开。这段关系不会变得更好。这十年也不是为别人做出深刻情感和精神牺牲的时候。那个时刻会到来。那个时刻会在以后到来，当你和某人结婚、在一起20年或30年之后。也许这也适用于每一个十年，不要和一个要求你牺牲自我身份以及你想要奉献给自己的时间和精力的人在一起。爱情应该只旨在提升你的生活。如果你为了维持这段关系而苦苦挣扎，尤其是在这些年轻的岁月里，所有的这些努力都被从你自己的发展以及投入到
your dream life. I think we often want to cling on to these relationships, even when they're not working out of that fear that we won't have value if we don't have a partner. And we talked about this in the stigma of being single episode, this patriarchal historical influence that continuously reinforces that if we are not dating, if we don't have someone in our lives, if we're not looking for someone, somehow there's something about us that's deficient or something about us that's shameful or wrong that maybe we can't attract love or that we are doing things in a way that is counter to what our culture and our society expects us to do, which is to prioritize romance and love above all else. But they should not be constraining you, especially in what should be a
你梦想生活的时间中抽离了。我想我们经常想要紧紧抓住这些关系不放，即使它们并不顺利，也是出于一种恐惧：如果我们没有伴侣，我们就没有价值。我们在“单身污名”那一集里讨论过这一点，这种父权制的历史影响不断在强化这样一种观念：如果我们不约会，如果我们的生活中没有伴侣，如果我们没有在寻找伴侣，那么我们在某种程度上就是有缺陷的，或者在某种程度上我们是可耻的或不对劲的，也许我们无法吸引爱情，或者我们做事的方式违背了文化和社会的期望——社会期望我们把浪漫和爱情置于一切之上。但它们不应该束缚你，尤其是在本该是你自私的一段人生时期。
selfish period of your life. It's also important to remember that the relationships you have at this stage will influence how you form connection later on. So it's probably worth being a little bit picky. They've conducted recent studies on this that has demonstrated how our very early romantic experiences, our interactions, our relationships might be just as impactful for our attachment style as the ones we developed with our parents in childhood. I'm going to really reinforce that. We often think in psychology that how our attachment style is formed is mainly due to things like temperament but also parental influence. So if your parents were neglectful or really inconsistent with how they showed you unconditional love, that's going to influence how you connect and attach to people
同样重要的是要记住，你在这个阶段拥有的人际关系会影响你日后建立连接的方式。所以挑剔一点可能是值得的。最近针对这一点进行的研究表明，我们极早期的浪漫经历、互动和关系，对我们依恋风格的影响，可能丝毫不亚于我们在童年时期与父母培养的依恋风格。我要着重强调这一点。我们在心理学中经常认为，依恋风格的形成主要归因于诸如气质之类的因素，但也受到父母的影响。所以如果你的父母忽视你，或者在对你表现无条件爱意时非常反复无常，那将会影响你未来与人连接和依恋的方式。
in the future. But what some of these studies are showing us is that it is not just those early childhood experiences, but those early 20-something experiences as well. So it's better to be alone that in a situation that doesn't serve you because that doesn't just impact your present enjoyment of your life, but your future ability to actually form those intimate, vulnerable connections. It's a real privilege to learn who you are beyond someone else's identity or attachment to you. And some people don't get that. So I would say if it's not the right person, don't settle. I would much rather be single till I was 40 than settle now and find myself questioning my worth, my decisions, feeling lost and disconnected later on.
但其中一些研究向我们表明，不仅是那些早年童年经历，二十岁出头时的那些经历也同样重要。因此，单身也比身处一段对你无益的处境中要好，因为这不仅会影响你对当前生活的享受，还会影响你未来建立亲密、脆弱连接的能力。能够超越别人的身份或对你的依恋来了解真正的自己，这是一种真正的特权。有些人得不到这种机会。所以我想说，如果不是对的人，就不要将就。我宁愿单身到40岁，也不愿现在将就，结果在日后的人生中开始质疑自己的价值、自己的决定，感到迷茫和与世隔绝。
life. This leads to my next tip, which is to stay single as long as possible. And I think that's a combination of the above two tips. The reason I say this is because I really truly believe that our 20s are our decade for us to use to know ourselves better. This is the time before you have responsibility and obligations to fully engage in that self-discovery, that introspection, and the wrong relationship as we discussed above can interrupt that. So you need to spend more time falling in love with yourself than falling in love with people who bring you down, who make you question your work or who kind of suck everything out of you. We also have to face the reality that your time is limited and it really needs to be divided between numerous priorities and obligations. You have 24 hours
这就引出了我的下一个建议，那就是尽可能长时间地保持单身。我认为这是上述两条建议的结合。我之所以这么说，是因为我坚信，二十几岁是我们用来更好地了解自己的十年。这是在你承担责任和义务之前，全身心投入到自我发现、内省中的时期，而正如我们上面所讨论的，一段错误的关系会打断这一过程。所以你需要花更多的时间去爱自己，而不是去爱那些让你情绪低落、让你质疑自己的价值或者几乎榨干你一切的人。我们还必须面对现实：你的时间是有限的，它确实需要在众多的优先级和义务之间进行分配。你一天只有24小时，
in the day, you've got to spend some of that, you know, doing your basic needs, eating, sleeping, working, taking care of your body, spending time with friends, calling family, working on your projects. All of those things should come first and then you should have time for your relationship if that's something that you choose to do. But that time is still limited. So when you decide to invest time in someone, what is that taking away from? And is that a sacrifice you're willing to make at this point in your life? And the best relationships, they truly do occur when you have a good understanding of your wants, your needs, yourself, your values. That's incredibly attractive. That is what attracts good people into your life. The ones that you want to stay is that confidence
你必须花一部分时间去满足基本需求，吃饭、睡觉、工作、照顾身体、花时间陪朋友、给家人打电话、做自己的项目。所有这些事情都应该排在第一位，然后如果你选择这样做的话，你才应该把时间留给恋爱关系。但时间依然是有限的。所以当你决定把时间投资在某人身上时，这是从什么地方抽离出来的？这会是你在这个人生阶段愿意做出的牺牲吗？最美好的恋爱关系，确实发生在当你对自己的需求、欲望、自我和价值观有了很好的理解之后。那具有无与伦比的吸引力。那正是将优秀的人吸引到你生活中的原因。让你想要留下来的是那种自信
and that self-awareness. And I think when we're desperate, when we don't have a clear sense of who we are without other people, we really see relationships or a partner as just a box to tick to prevent feelings of loneliness or feelings of inadequacy. And I never think that we should be in a relationship in our 20s or at any age for those reasons. Finally, my last tip is to embrace heartbreak and fall in love hard. Now, that might sound counterintuitive based on what I've previously said, but remember, we're thinking about choosing the right people here. And I also think that we shouldn't be scared of loving deeply and having our heartbroken. Heartbreak creates very real physical pain. We know that. We've seen that in MRI studies looking at how our pain receptors are activated
和自我意识。我想，当我们绝望时，当我们对没有其他人时的自己没有清晰的认识时，我们真的把恋爱关系或伴侣仅仅看作是一个打卡项目，用来消除孤独感或无价值感。我绝不认为我们应该因为这些原因而在二十几岁或任何年龄谈恋爱。最后，我的最后一条建议是：拥抱心碎，勇敢去爱。现在，根据我之前所说的话，这听起来可能有些违背直觉，但请记住，我们在这里考虑的是选择对的人。而且我也认为我们不应该害怕深深地去爱以及承受心碎。心碎会带来非常真实的身体痛苦。我们知道这一点。我们在核磁共振研究中看到过这一点，这些研究显示我们的痛觉感受器被
by emotional pain, just as much as physical pain. So as humans, I think we instinctually want to avoid that. We want to avoid deep vulnerable connections because it's innate to kind of some of our survival instincts, especially if we've been hurt in the past. But I think the depth of emotions created by getting your heart tremendously, irreparably broken is an experience that is such a blessing and that we all need to have in our 20s. Because it pushes you to a place of such depth, of such knowing. It gives you empathy. It makes you more in touch with yourself. It makes you more creative. And that time in which everything seems chaotic in which your heart is literally aching really gives you the moment to figure out who you are and what you want your future to look like.
情感痛苦激活的程度，与身体痛苦不相上下。因此，作为人类，我想我们本能地想要避免这种情况。我们想要避免深度的、脆弱的连接，因为这是我们某些生存本能的一部分，尤其是如果我们过去曾受过伤的话。但我认为，因为心碎得彻底、无可挽回而产生的情感深度，是一种极其幸运的体验，也是我们所有人在二十几岁时都需要的经历。因为它会把你推到一个拥有如此深度、如此认知的境地。它赋予你共情能力。它让你更能触及内心。它让你更具创造力。而那段一切似乎都混乱不堪、你的心确实在隐隐作痛的时光，真正给了你一个时刻去弄清楚你是谁，以及你希望自己的未来是什么样子。
Some people scare us out of loving heart. They make us feel embarrassed or ashamed for being really, really open with how we're feeling and choosing to really dive in deeply into those vulnerable loving moments. But I think a set an example. Don't shut yourself down because of someone else's inability to feel deeply because of their emotional unavailability. Don't let them kind of callous your heart and make you feel like you are not a deeply emotional and sensitive person and that is not a beautiful thing because it is that makes you such a beautiful person. And I think each heartbreak in our lives has this opportunity and has this unique ability to teach us something really valuable. I think it is so sacred in a way. I wouldn't really
有些人把我们吓得不敢深爱。他们让我们因为在表达感受时表现得极其坦诚、并选择深深沉浸在那些脆弱而充满爱的时刻而感到尴尬或羞耻。但我认为，要树立一个榜样。不要因为别人无力深爱、因为他们的情感冷漠而关闭自己的心扉。不要让他们把你的心变得冷酷无情，让你觉得自己不是一个极具情感和敏感的人，并且觉得这不是一件美好的事，因为这确实是一件美好的事，它让你成为一个如此美好的人。而且我认为我们生活中的每一次心碎，都有这样的机遇和这种独特的能力，来教给我们一些非常宝贵的东西。在某种程度上，我认为这是极其神圣的。如果没有我的心碎，我真的
have the life I have now without my heartbreak. So I'm so grateful to those people in hindsight for not only letting me feel the full spectrum of human emotion to feel human, but also giving me the encouragement to be better and to wait for the person who would reciprocate my love and to not let myself be kind of hollowed out by hurt. You need to, I think, just push and rush and fall in love as much as possible and let your heart be broken and let it be raw and let be open to those experiences because that's what makes life so spectacular is having that connection with this broad depth of human emotion. So finally, I want to finish with my seven tips for personal growth that help us create our dream life in our 20s. Seven things that I think we all need to
不会拥有现在的生活。所以回想起来，我非常感谢那些人，不仅让我感受到了人类情感的全谱以体会做人的感觉，还给予我鼓励让我变得更好，去等待那个会回应我的爱的人，并且不让自己被伤害掏空。我认为，你需要去拼搏、去冲动、尽可能多地去爱，让你的心碎裂，让它保持赤诚，对这些经历保持开放，因为这正是让生活如此壮丽的原因——拥有与这种广泛而深厚的人类情感的连接。最后，我想以我关于个人成长的七条建议来结束，这些建议帮助我们在二十几岁时创造梦想的生活。我认为我们所有人都需要在这十年里努力或专注的七件事，以充分利用这段经历。首先，放下你的自我。自我（Ego）是一个弗洛伊德概念。它是我们的自我意识。它是我们对自己做对我们最有利的事情的责任感。它是我们解读情境的方式。当这一点没有得到控制时，它确实会把我们与某些经历隔绝开来。因为自我的运作方式有两种。一种方式是告诉我们，我们不配
work on or focus on during this decade to get the most out of this experience. Firstly, let go of your ego. So ego is this Freudian concept. It's our sense of self. It's our sense of responsibility to our self to do what's best for us. And it's the way that we interpret situations. When that is not kept in check, that can really cut us off from certain experiences. Because ego operates in two ways. One way is telling us that we're not deserved. of certain things, and the other way is telling us that we're too deserving. So I think where there is pride, there is missed opportunity. You are not too good or not good enough for any experience or any opportunity. And I think that when we let go of our ego and when we see ourselves as a bit
得到某些东西，另一种方式是告诉我们，我们太配得到了。所以我想，哪里有傲慢，哪里就有错失的良机。对于任何经历或任何机会，你并没有好到高攀不起，也没有糟到不配拥有。我想，当我们放下自我，把自身看作是一张白纸，让任何经历成为人生叙事的一部分，让人们进入我们的生活时，我们会从这十年中收获更多。我的第二条建议，也是我们认为在这十年中大家都需要去做的事，那就是解开你的童年创伤和童年情感创伤。我们知道我们在童年时期的经历会影响我们成人的视角和情感处理方式。这可能会产生终生的影响。而我们的二十几岁，我认为正是我们开始认识到并意识到那些早期经历如何继续在日后给我们带来痛苦和麻烦的时候。所以我们有责任真正去解决这些问题，趁我们还拥有这种思维的灵活性，趁那些记忆还鲜活的时候。因此，我认为我们需要审视的一些创伤包括：
of a blank canvas, letting any experience become part of the narrative, letting people into our lives, we get a lot more out of this decade. My second tip, that we, I think, we all really need to do in our 20s is to unpack your childhood trauma and your childhood emotional wounds. We know that the experiences we have in childhood influence our adult perspectives and emotional approaches. And that can have a lifelong impact. And our 20s, I think, is when we first begin to recognize and become cognizant of the ways that some of those early experiences are still causing pain and trouble for us later in life. So we have a duty to really address those whilst we still have that mental flexibility, whilst those memories are fresh. So some of the wounds I think we need
负罪感创伤。小时候是什么让你感到内疚？被抛弃创伤。有哪些时刻你觉得没有被爱，这如何反映在你当前的连接方式以及你认为自己配得上怎样的生活上？背叛创伤，你曾在过去如何感到被他人辜负？这又如何影响你认为别人将来会辜负你的方式？最后，忽视创伤。小时候有什么是你没有得到、但现在依然需要的？这些事情会影响我们，我认为现在就处理它们，真正投入到一些内省、自我成长、自我意识中，是对我们未来乃至当下的一笔重要的长期投资。
to examine are things like the guilt wound. What made you feel guilty as a child? The abandonment wound. When were there times that you didn't feel loved and how was that being reflected in your current approach to connection and to what you deserve from your life? betrayal wound, how have you felt let down by people in your past? And how is that influencing how you think people will let you down in the future? And finally, the neglect wound. What were you not given as a child that you still need? These things will impact us and I think dealing with them now, really engaging in some of that introspection, that self-growth, that self-awareness is an important long-term investment in our future and in our present moment as well.
第三，这一条关于自信。你必须开始“假装直到你真正拥有它”。你知道，这是我最近学到的一点：没有人能真正分辨出你是在假装自信、假装感觉良好，还是你本来就是如此。我认为这种近乎自我煤气灯式的、对自己说的谎，会给你带来我们在这十年里都在追求的自信，并建立你的自尊。我认为二十几岁不是一个该去担心身材之类事情的年龄，也不是一个去担心
Thirdly, this one's about confidence. You got to start faking it till you make it. You know, it's something that I've learned recently that no one can really tell the difference between when you're pretending that you're confident, when you're pretending that you feel amazing, and when you actually are. And I think that that almost self-gaslighting, that self-lie that you tell yourself, gives you the confidence that we're all after during this decade and it builds your self-esteem. I think our 20s are not a time to be worrying about things like our bodies or worrying about things
我们穿什么、别人怎么看我们，或者因为不相信自己而对各种情境退缩的年龄。当你开始假装那种自信，当你开始感到勇敢并告诉自己你很勇敢时，你的大脑，尤其是你的潜意识，真的开始相信它了，它就变成你现实的一部分，而不仅仅是一个幻想或你对自己说的话。你知道，你的大脑会积极监测你的行为来决定你的情绪。这是一种被称为生物反馈的东西。所以当你假装自信，当你假装快乐，当你假装，我猜，真正充满自信时，这就会转化为一种真实的感受。
like what we're wearing or what people think about us or holding back from situations because we don't believe in ourselves. And when you start to fake that level of confidence, when you start to feel brave and tell yourself that you're brave, your mind, especially your unconscious mind, really begins to believe it and it becomes a part of your reality rather than just a fantasy or something that you're telling yourself. You know, your mind actively monitors your behavior to determine your mood. It's this thing called, it's kind of like a version of biofeedback. So when you pretend to be confident, when you pretend to be happy, when you pretend to be, I guess, really self-assured, that translates into a real sense of that feeling.
我认为这是真正把自己当回事的时期。做事情不是因为你觉得它们会给别人留下深刻印象，而是因为你想做。做一些有点离经叛道的事，去创造故事，而不用担心别人的评判，去练习自信，把它融入你的心态和生活方式中。第四，照顾好你的身体。你知道，这不是一个担心外表的时候，这不是一个虚荣的时候，但这是一个意识到你的身体是你永远的家、它没有你哪儿也去不了的时候，它确实是我们拥有的唯一的身体。我想人们年长时表达的很多遗憾，以及人们希望
And I think this is the time to really think of yourself as the shit. To do things not because you think they're going to impress other people, but because you want to do them. To do things that are a little bit outrageous and go and make stories without worrying about judgment from other people to practice self-confidence, to bring it into your mindset and your approach to your life. Fourth, take care of your body. You know, it's not a time to worry about looks. it's not a time for vanity but it is a time to realize that your body is your forever home and it's not going to go anywhere without you it is truly the only body that we have and I think a lot of the regrets that people express when they're older and a lot of the things that people wish
自己当初做过的事，就是在更容易做到的时候更好地照顾自己。所以我不是说要进行那种彻底的 75天硬核改造，而是去思考那些可以用善意对待身体的小方法，那些可以感谢它陪你度过每一天、一直陪伴着你、承载你经历每一件事的小方法。第五，我觉得这一条超级不言自明。如果你正处于二十多岁，我猜你正是。我想是时候去看心理医生了。我知道这是每个人都在说的话，但他们这么说是有非常充分的理由的。
they had done is take better care of themselves when it was easier to do that so I'm not saying do like a full-on 75 hard transformation but think about the small ways that you can treat your body with kindness and the small ways that you can thank it for getting you through every day, for being there with you, for carrying you through every single experience. Fifth, this one I feel like is super self-explanatory. If you're on your 20s, I'm guessing you are. I think it's time to go to therapy. And I know that that is something that everyone says, but they say it for a really good reason.
这又回到了之前的那个建议，关于（你知道的）放下自我、理解童年创伤。现在就去做那些工作来了解自己、了解是什么触发了你、了解你身上背负着哪些影响你行为的东西，这是极其极其宝贵的。它带给你一种我认为很多人所不具备的觉悟。而这种觉悟在我们生活中的体现，尤其是对那些没有这样做的人来说，就是当他们到了30岁或40岁时，直到那时他们才真正开始剖析为什么自己会有这种感觉。
And it links back to that earlier tip about, you know, letting go of your ego, understanding your childhood wounds. Doing that work now to know yourself, to know what triggers you, to know what things you're carrying with you that impact your behavior is so, so valuable. And it gives you an awareness that I think a lot of people don't have. And the way that that shows up in our lives, and especially for the people who don't do this, is that they reach 30 or 40, and it's only then that they really start to unpack why they feel the way they do.
并不是说到了那时就太晚了，而是到了那时他们已经错过了宝贵的10年、15年、20年，在这期间他们本可以对自己的经历有更多觉悟，本可以和自己握手言和，本可以去实践那些能够指导我们做决定、让我们做出更好决定、让我们成为更快乐的人的自我之爱与自我觉悟。我的下一个建议是找一个爱好或你热爱做的事。我想当我们像在二十几岁时这样过渡到成年时，我们发现的一个主要现象就是我们的时间大部分都被工作占据了。
And it's not that by then it's too late, but it's that by then they've missed a good 10, 15, 20 years in which they maybe could have been more aware of what they were going through and could really shake hands with who they are and really practice some of that self-love and some of that self-awareness that guides our decisions and allows us to make better decisions, allows us to just be happier people. My next tip is to find a hobby or something that you love doing. I think when we transition into adulthood as we are doing in our 20s, a major experience we find is that a lot of our time becomes dominated by work.
而且我认为，我们很容易变成单维度的生物，变成那些不关注或不优先考虑真正让我们快乐的事情的单维度存在。爱好对于赋予你个人复杂性和维度、激活心流状态并给你带来快乐、激活你不想失去的大脑的不同部分来说，简直太棒了。你知道，就是那句老话，“不用进则退”。但我们也可以说，当你选择激活不同的神经通路以及大脑甚至身体的不同部分去创造某些东西、做某些事情或玩耍时，这是保持我们头脑活跃、对生活保持兴趣、让我们沉浸在让我们快乐的事情之中的一种非常非常宝贵的方式。所以找一个你热爱的爱好，它可能不会持续一辈子，但身边总有一些能让你成为一个多维度之人的事物，对这十年来说超级超级宝贵。而我为这个系列画上句号的最后一条建议是：要傻气一点，要享受乐趣。
And it becomes very easy, I think, for us to be very one-dimensional creatures and one-dimensional beings who don't focus or prioritize on what actually makes us happy. Hobbies are amazing for giving yourself, I guess, intricacy and dimension to your person to also activating a bit of a flow state and bringing you enjoyment, activating different parts of your brain that you don't want to lose. You know, it's that saying of, you know, use it or lose it. But we can also say that When you choose to activate your different neural pathways and different parts of your brain and even your body to create something or do something or to play, that is a really, really valuable way of keeping our mind alive, keeping us interested in life, keeping us engaged in what's making us happy. So finding a hobby that you love, you know, might not be forever, but always having something on the side that makes you a multi-dimensional person is super, super valuable for this decade. And my final tip to end this series is to be silly, is to have fun.
天哪，我觉得自己就像个小学老师，或者像个，我不知道，就像个高中老师一样，在这里说：“我们的首要任务是什么？要享受乐趣！”但真的，这是你完全享受快乐的时期。我们不想在一个感觉非常动荡和压倒一切的时期里失去这一点。玩耍。参与玩耍。傻气一点。寻找方法来真正激活你身上那个热爱乐趣的部分，去犯错，去嘲笑自己，
And oh my goodness, I feel like such a primary school teacher or like a, I don't know, like a high school teacher here being like, what's our number one priority to have fun? But really, this is your time to be completely joyful. We don't want to lose that during what feels like a really tumultuous and overwhelming period. Play. Engage in play. Be silly. find ways to really activate that fun loving part of you, to make mistakes, to laugh at yourself,
去创造一些可能会令人尴尬、可能会让人觉得脚趾抠地的有趣故事，但它们真正留下的，只是美丽、精彩的回忆。所以我想参与玩耍不仅有着非常重要的心理益处，而且在情感上对我们大有裨益，在精神上也对我们大有裨益。它还能让我们专注于当下，让我们不断在生活中寻找快乐。我真的很讨厌有时候我们觉得自己不得不成长得太快，做出很多决定，突然之间我们到了25岁就成了成年人，或者到了21岁就成了成年人，而所有那种童真的惊叹都消失了。但我希望如果你现在正在听这个，你不会成为那种人。
to make funny stories that might be embarrassing, they might be cringe, but what they really are is just beautiful, wonderful memories. So I think engaging in play doesn't just have really important psychological benefits, but it's so good for us emotionally, it's so good for us mentally. it keeps us in the present moment as well, and it keeps us searching for joy in our lives. I really hate that sometimes we feel like we have to grow up too quickly and make a lot of decisions, and suddenly we turn 25 and we're adults, or we turn 21 and we're adults, and all of that childlike wonder disappears. But I'm hoping that if you're listening to this right now, you're not going to become one of those people.
你是一个会优先选择保持傻气、保持冒险精神、让自己活在当下并寻找快乐的人。那么，关于如何在二十几岁时创造梦想生活的这个迷你系列节目到这里就全部结束了。如果你还没有听过第一集，我们在那一集里更深入地探讨了职业、财务、承担风险、辞职，以及所有与职业和财务发展相关的内容。我知道这个系列只有两部分，但在制作它的时候，我在想，这里面还有很多我可以讲的内容。我们可以做一个完整的专题节目，讨论你如何从身体上对待自己，以及在二十几岁时照顾心理健康、创造梦想生活的方法。但目前，我们还是把它限制在这五个类别中。
you're someone who is going to prioritize being silly, keeping the adventure alive, keeping yourself in the present moment and looking for joy. So that is going to conclude this little mini-series on how to create your dream life in your 20s. If you haven't already listened to episode one, we talk a lot more in depth around career, finances, are taking risks, quitting your job, everything to kind of do with professional and financial development. And I know the series was only two parts, but in making it, I was like, there is so much more here that I could say. We could do like an entire component episode on how you treat yourself physically and ways to take care of your mental health and your 20s to create your dream life. But for now, we're going to keep it to these five categories.
我真的希望你喜欢这一集。我自己也是个二十几岁的人。所以我不会说这是专家的建议，但希望这能给你带来一些安慰：很多人都在经历和你一样的困惑、两难和体验，这能让你感到安心。我们都在努力摸索，我们都会犯错误，但错误只是美丽的教训和美丽的故事。这就是这十年的意义所在，不是试图把所有事情都做对，而是试图带着对生活的热爱去做所有事情，带着兴奋和能量去做所有事情。所以我希望这个信息能非常强烈地传递出来，
And I really do hope that you enjoyed this episode. I'm still someone in my 20s. So I'm not going to say this is expert advice, but hopefully it is. is comforting to know that a lot of people out there are having the same conundrums, dilemmas, experiences that you are. We are all trying to figure it out and we are going to make mistakes, but mistakes are just beautiful lessons and beautiful stories. And that's what this decade is all about, not trying to do everything right, but trying to do everything with life and do everything with excitement and with energy. So I hope that message has come through really
无论是通过这一集，还是通过我们在本系列中做的第一集。和往常一样，如果你喜欢这一集，如果你喜欢这个节目，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方给它一个五星好评。把它分享给朋友。你永远不知道谁可能需要听听这些建议。我不知道这算不算好建议，但即使是坏建议，也许你们也可以探讨一下我在哪里出了错。如果是这样的话，请随时向我反馈。如果有节目建议，或者你只想看看幕后花絮、即将推出的内容或视频内容，请在 Instagram 上那个心理学播客联系我。我喜欢看那个社群在那里不断壮大。非常感谢你收听这一集，如果你也听了第一集的话，也谢谢你收听第一集。我们下周会带着另一集回归。到时候见。
strongly in this episode and the first episode we did on this series as well. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, if you like the show, please feel free to give it a five-star review on Apple podcast, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. Share it with a friend. You never know who might need to hear some of this advice. I don't know if it was good advice, but even if it's bad advice, maybe you can have a little discussion over where I went wrong. Please feel free to for me if that is the case. And get in contact at that psychology podcast on Instagram. If you have an episode suggestion, if you just want to see behind the scenes or what's
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，
coming up or video content, I love to see the community grow over there. And thank you so much for listening to this episode and to the first episode as well if you were there for that. We will be back next week with another episode. So see you then. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host. care games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that
这些对话在其他任何地方真的都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去听《Learn the Hard Way》，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这段怀孕经历似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你对这个特定的测试动过两次手脚，对吗？我动过一次手脚。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。
it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was a accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
另外两个经历过相同事情的男人：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天哪，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱网》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听播客《Love Trapped》。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立适应力的科学。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉勒斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上搜索 TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他绝不能就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。这是一档 iHeart 播客，真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。